- Twist, we're all drunk.
(everyone laughs)
- Give me all the cards.
- I'm not an athlete.
- I have nails on so this is currently,
- Why do I have the highest heels ever?
- Is that all the cards?
- Guys I can't get, I
can't get more than one.
- That's an indication.
- Are you drunk?
(everyone laughs)
- But I think they all went to her side.
- Yeah I got, I did get
lucky, I did get lucky.
- Who's going first?
- You go?
- Oh me? (blows raspberry)
- No, uh-uh, no.
- What?
- At least three rows and down.
- For sure.
- It's only round one. (laughs)
- Oh (bleep), this is like, not good.
Can I change my mind?
- Nope.
- (bleep)
(cricket chirping)
(everyone laughs)
- You touched it, you may
have made a massive mistake.
- You cannot hold it
- Ah, are you kidding me?
- Is this like legit
Jenga or is it bootleg?
- This is the real Jenga, no you have to,
- What, what, what are you, have you,
- Oh, oh, my god, okay, okay.
- You are definitely drunk.
- Alright, time to get it moving.
- She was overly confident.
- Just touch the damn things. (laughs)
- Don't get so aggressive.
- Well the bet is who's drunk.
- Oh, yeah, but money is also better.
- Money's great.
- Oh!
- What?
- Alright, now let's kick it into gear.
- I would've started to try. (both laugh)
(everyone laughs)
- You got it, just go
straight of that to steal it.
- This is a drunk pal talk.
- They're like the two drunk girls
in the backroom that are
hyping each other up.
- [Together] Whoa...
(everyone yells)
- Why'd you flick it?
- 'Cause (bleep) it.
- [Together] Two words, first word,
- Second word.
- [Various Voices] High,
teacher, school, kindergarten,
first grade,
- Eighth grade!
- Yeah. The movie's called Eighth Grade.
- I don't know that film.
- I don't know that film either.
- [Together] Three words, Lion King.
- Yeah!
(everyone laughs)
- Did you say three words?
- The Lion King
- Oh, The Lion King.
- [Together] Three words.
- Third word, third word.
- The third word, third word.
- [Various Voices] First
two words, second word,
second, first two words,
L.A, Los Angeles,
- La La Land. Yeah!
(everyone yells)
- Okay, this is really hard.
- [Together] Three words, the third word.
Heart, love, love, crazy
in love, Crazy Stupid Love.
- Oh, jeez.
- Singing, opera, Shakespeare In Love.
- Yeah!
- Good one.
- What?
- Oh, my god.
- She was singing
to the balcony.
- I don't know what I was doing, but.
(all laugh)
- You're drunk.
- You know what, you're drunk because
you haven't accused one
person here of being drunk,
'cause you know you're drunk.
- That's fair.
- [Together] Three words, one, first word.
- [Various Voices] Hi,
wave, hello, wave, hello,
hi, grumpy, grumpy hi, reach.
- I don't know how to do it, okay.
- What? What else could this be?
- [Various Voices] Squat, school, pee,
is this the first word still, school,
classroom related,
test, (everyone laughs).
- [Together] School of Rock!
(everyone laughs)
- We did it.
- Yeah.
- I forgot how to do
math, do we have to do
like exactly 20 percent?
(various laughter)
- Okay, but you add the
percent to the total,
or what the percent is?
- What are you doing?
- Oh, my god.
- Why are you doing the most complicated?
- Just do the diff.
- I have very little time.
- This is what I would put.
- Is mine right?
- I think yours is righter than mine,
but, we're close yes.
- Oh, we all got the same receipt?
- We have the same.
- All you do is just
take 10 percent and then times it by two.
- Oh, I didn't do that, I
just did the regular version,
I didn't break it down.
- Maybe between these two.
- Adriana.
- 'Cause that thing was hella long
but you've been looking
drunk from the beginning.
(everyone laughs)
- You're very accusatory, though,
so that makes you feel it.
- That's true.
- Good lord, okay.
Well can I start off with the fact
that this is used as a test
in Japanese internment camps?
Because they knew that they would fail.
- She's talking politics, she's drunk.
- So Z, Y, X, and I'm out.
- Nope, it's wrong, I'm right, it's wrong.
(everyone laughs)
- Oh, V, U, oh, yeah, it's V, U, T?
- Did you start, where did
you start getting wrong?
H?
- No.
- That's hard. (laughs)
- Not drunk.
- Uh.
(everyone laughs)
- Yes.
- Drunk.
- Badge of honor.
- This is hard.
Can we smell them?
Only because you flicked it.
- She's pacing like she's,
- Should we just trade?
- I think that's a good guess.
- You did act the most drunk
but I feel like that just
might be your personality.
- You could just be a really fun person.
- Yeah, you are.
(various laughter)
Yeah it's your personality, I
might have to change my guess.
- That's the thing,
yeah, personality-wise,
I can't blame people, I'm so sorry.
- It's okay.
- She could also just be high.
- That's possible.
(everyone laughs)
It's perfectly legal.
- What, about myself?
(everyone laughs)
I drank zinfandel (laughs)
This is zinfandel. I'm hiding in
a meeting room, I was told to drink
as much as I can.
(saxophone music)
- It was clear that you were drunk
'cause you tried so hard to
pretend that you weren't drunk.
Especially playing Jenga you were like,
(groans) trying to focus.
- Mm.
- I think you had it when you were like,
she's not accusing anyone else.
- Yeah, she was the only person
that didn't say anyone else.
- 'Cause everyone else was like
drunk, drunk, drunk, drunk.
- I wanna see what you're like
sober and see how they compare.
- I'm just as fun.
(everyone laughs)
- Oh, everybody wins a bottle?
(glasses clink)
(everyone laughs)
- [Adriana] Where's my
unfinished bottle, though?
Can Jessica and I split that?
(upbeat music)